I'm gonna show you some images now I
want you to tell me the first thing that
you see political revolution really no
this is Donald Trump's new middle east
it's called Amaris tan bernie sanders
has endorsed his centrist nemesis
Hillary Clinton
he says the Democrats need political
unity but what do his supporters need
political therapy I hear you are going
through a general election how's that
been it's been rough feel sad and angry
when was the first time that you felt
the Bern I felt the Bern from the very
beginning what is the Bern feel like
it's kind of a cool sensation it's like
a tiger balm really mm-hmm
can I ask you when you first knew you
were progressive yeah that was when I
was in high school when I volunteered
for Ralph Nader
and the Green Party so you have a
history of outside candidates you know I
met a lot of people on the campaign
knocked on thousands of doors and it's
really a beautiful couple months we had
and you know sometimes just doesn't work
out you don't think he gave up on the
relationship there just wasn't enough
there to keep it going
was the fire gone the fire has been
taken for I think by someone new named
Donald Trump what do you need to put out
the fire will lead I think that we might
need Hillary how does it make you feel
to say I'm with her
it hurts it's like paying taxes you have
to do it you don't do it you have
consequences
how have you processed all of these
feelings I weighed out into the you know
the storm sometimes but then I'll come
back to the center and recuperate you
could say that about the Democratic
Party they weighed out but then they
mostly just come back to the center
although the dance of platforms moves a
little bit is I don't think Killers
gonna budge TPP she's gonna it's gonna
reform and meet her standards when you
do her in air quotes is that just some
unresolved feelings between yourself and
your mother a little bit whatever you
see there's no right or wrong answer
masquerade mask
oh yes that's actually a Vladimir Putin
and Donald Trump conspiring about how to
divvy up Ukraine you know I think this
is a what our democracy could look like
if we actually had a democracy all these
little blocks like they're all on the
outside and they come together to form a
coalition a little delusional but you
know that's okay nothing we can't work
for him Libya Honduras the Iraqi war as
a business model yeah that's lots of
deleted emails emails you see deleted
emails I see a 60 something-year-old
woman who doesn't know how to use her
phone imagine that I am senator Sanders
and just tell me what you would tell him
awesome all thank you for everything
you've done for our campaign you're
welcome but that doesn't help with what
you did you endorsed Hillary Clinton you
betrayed us
you let backstabbers actually try and
take your voters and you're telling them
to actually vote for them that's the way
politics works
but are we trying to change this and I
think we have do I have your forgiveness
from the bottom of my heart I forgive
you Bernie Sanders okay that was great
I think we really made a breakthrough
here thank you for sharing
Obamacare governance know